in an interview with her she was asking
me about people that I don't like in the
NBA and I said I hate Chris Paul easily
100% my least favorite person in the NBA
you get something sent to your phone I'm
saying something like that what were you
thinking of what was being said got in
that group chat when that came out I
don't know which time that was first and
foremost cuz you said it a few times if
we gonna keep it funy I always say this
when anybody say something I say i' be
everywhere like I said I'm president of
the union for 8 years it's been a few
guys in this league who would go out
here and say something about me and then
what what I always say I'm everywhere
everywhere I'm everywhere I'm at the
meetings I done had guys who would talk
crazy about me on a on a podcast or a
show and then they come up to me before
a game and be like hey yo see what we
going to do as far as the union stuff is
we GNA play and I be looking like